bom era janeiro de 2015
fazia poucos meses do atentado
terrorista ao jornal charlie hebdo em
paris no mundo todo vários casos de
ataques xenófobos começaram a aparecer
ao redor do mundo
em são paulo o caso de uma mulher
ela foi apedrejada enquanto levava os
filhos pequenos para a escola quando
contava com os meus amigos que estava
acontecendo
ninguém acreditava no brasil essas
coisas não acontecem não é possível
foi aí que eu convidei uma amiga minha
pra gente dar uma volta pelo centro de
curitiba para perceber a reação das
pessoas
enquanto isso ela filmava com uma câmera
escondida nas costas foi bem
impressionante perceber que as maiores
reações de preconceito
vieram de pessoas que frequentavam uma
região que se tornou referência cultural
da cidade
pessoas que teoricamente se dizem
abertos à diversidade
lógico que a roupa por si só ela
desperta curiosidade mas a curiosidade
ela se transforma em preconceito quando
você passa e as pessoas fazem o sinal da
cruz
ou elas começam a fazer barulho de bom
apenas suas costas
bom eu fiz essa experiência para tentar
entender um pouquinho como o brasileiro
enxerga a sua diversidade
eu não sou muçulmana e não sou árabe
na verdade eu sou bisneta de um judeu
refugiado no brasil
depois as perseguições nazistas na
europa e eu cresci ouvindo as histórias
da minha família e foi fácil perceber
que esse tipo de perseguição pode
acontecer com qualquer um de nós o que
determina é o contexto que a gente está
inserido mas vou voltar à história desde
o início para vocês entenderem um
pouquinho melhor ela a meados de 2010
estava na faculdade
várias festas várias perspectivas para o
futuro
mas na verdade eu não estava feliz foi
aí que resolvi que era um era hora de
realizar um grande sonho da minha vida
e morar um tempo fora do brasil eu pedi
demissão do meu estágio juntei todas as
minhas economias
contem com uma grande ajuda da minha
família e fui morar um tempo fora
fui para a irlanda quando cheguei lá eu
quis morar numa casa de família desde o
início porque eu queria ter essa troca
cultural saber tudo o que eles tinham
para agregar e a casa que eu acabei
ficando na verdade um verdadeiro caos
muitas pessoas muitos animais por todos
os lados e no café da manhã e só
conseguia trocar uma idéia com a panela
que era dona da casa mas no resto do dia
eu passava com a danielle e com a chery
a danielle ela tinha dois anos de idade
e até agora cachorro da família
eu digo que eu melhorei muito meu inglês
morando com eles mas a verdade é que sim
eu melhorei o meu inglês assistindo o
papg com a danielle e eu queria tanto
trocar experiências com eles e vivências
e conhecer um pouquinho mais mas a
verdade é que ali eu só tinha virado uma
renda extra para aquela família já que
não conseguia ter essa troca dentro de
casa eu fui tentar isso no trabalho
primeiro eu trabalhei num pub e eu
entregava alguns bônus nas ruas até que
um dia seu desgosto de beber um
pouquinho mais
é um homem parou na minha frente e me
perguntou onde eu era quando eu falei
que era que eu era brasileira ele abriu
o casaco e aquela pelada por baixo
aquilo me chocou de uma forma que eu
nunca mais conseguiu voltar lá
depois disso eu fui trabalhar numa
sorveteria
lá nós éramos só estrangeiros
trabalhando e por isso também um alvo
muito comum dos hackers na kers é um
grupo de adolescentes da periferia de
dublin capital da irlanda e que eles
vêem um estrangeiro como uma ameaça para
o país disse eles não têm a menor
preguiça de arrumar confusão
lógico a sorveteria era um alvo fácil e
constante deles um dia eu indo para o
trabalho um grupo de mini na casa de uns
13 e 14 anos começou a jogar a este
nível de água em cima de mim
só que no inverno na irlanda ela faz
muito frio eu passei o resto do dia
molhada no inverno e vendendo sorvete e
com
eles apareciam lá às vezes com um taco
de beisebol batendo nas janelas
às vezes eles enviavam a cabeça começava
os pintores os sorvetes ea gente tinha
que jogar todo o estoque fora ea gente
chama a polícia algumas chamado por isso
algumas vezes mas eles nunca se tornado
nenhuma nenhum chamado nosso mas enfim
era uma situação daquele contexto a
gente aprender a lidar com aquilo
no final daquele ano eu não tinha nenhum
plano pra virada do ano lhe natal e ano
novo e eu tava quase voltando para o
brasil eu decidi que eu queria viajar um
pouquinho e ao redor com os seus países
em volta e então eu ia abrir mão do meu
natal ano novo e ficar trabalhando já
que os salários eram pagos por hora e eu
fiquei problema é que os meus
empregadores sabiam exatamente qual era
a minha data de partida e eles foram me
enrolando enrolando
resumindo a história eu nunca vi esse
dinheiro eu não pude fazer essa viagem
eu voltei pro brasil
eu até podia ter feito qualquer tipo de
reclamação por alguma autoridade local
mas o máximo que eles iam fazer é uma
reclamação para o dono do
estabelecimento aplicar algum tipo de
multa
eu estava de mãos atadas ainda mas enfim
voltei pro brasil várias outras mudanças
aconteceram na minha vida e com certeza
a maior delas foi a maternidade quando
bernardo nasceu e começou a me dar uma
crise de propósito
simplesmente não fazia mais sentido eu
trabalhar ganhar um dinheiro pra pagar
as contas no final do mês
eu queria mais que se eu começar a me
questionar qualquer realmente a minha
expectativa na vida o que eu queria
fazer
eu vou acabei voltando do trabalho que o
anterior à viagem e tinha falado que eu
precisava fazer um evento sobre inovação
só que pra mim até então inovação era
sua tecnologia e não entendia
absolutamente nada daquilo eu fiquei
desesperada foi meu deus que eu vou
fazer
comecei a pesquisar conversei com várias
pessoas e aí acabei descobrindo que
tinha muita gente por aí é descobrindo
formas de ganhar dinheiro resolvendo
problemas sociais
eu fiquei em casa
nada com aquilo de repente várias portas
começaram a se abrir na minha frente e
eu descobri um mundo totalmente novo
foi desse jeito que eu conheci o
empreendedorismo social
logo depois é enquanto eu fazia um tempo
depois enquanto fazia hora entre sair do
trabalho e para a faculdade eu passei
numa lanchonete que tinha ali por perto
fui tomar um suco e conheci o maduro ele
trabalhava numa lanchonete como chapeiro
mandou ele é um senegalês de 28 anos
engenheiro
fluente em cinco idiomas e pai de um
menino de quatro anos
só que mandou teve que deixar o senegal
por uma série de problemas que o país
enfrentava mas ele não tinha condições
financeiras de trazer toda a família
então ele acabou indo sozinho no brasil
entre pagar a pensão que ele vivia
mandar dinheiro por filho ele vivia com
350 reais por mês
só que a história do amado não é única
existe um milhão de outras histórias
muito parecidas com a dele por aí e foi
entendendo todo esse potencial que tinha
sido dispersado que entende exatamente
onde eu queria chegar
as experiências que eu tinha tido esse
intercâmbio
o que eu tinha aprendido na faculdade de
relações internacionais e o que eu sabia
fazer o meu trabalho
foi aí que as coisas começaram a se
conectar de alguma forma uma dessas
conexões e eu acredito muito que quando
a gente tem convicção em algo que a
gente faz
parece que o universo conspira e as
coisas acontecem mesmo assim sem a gente
esperava
numa dessas conexões eu fui parar no
acre junto com um amigo fotógrafo da
national geographic e lan
a gente foi ver de perto o que a este
ano os senegaleses estavam passando na
mão de traficantes de pessoas
a gente viu de perto uma caderneta de
poupança escrita à mão todos os saques
bancários da viagem de porto príncipe
até rio branco 5 mil dólares
esse era o preço médio do recomeço a
gente atravessou a fronteira com o peru
andamos mais um
nos 300 quilômetros pela floresta
amazônica em estradas com buracos
pareciam banheiros ea gente entendeu que
o problema estava aqui do nosso lado
também é o brasil hoje tem um número
considerável baixa até de imigrantes um
país como a jordânia que tenha a mesma
área santa catarina por exemplo 20% da
população são de refugiados sírios
aqui no brasil a gente tem 0,9 por cento
da população de imigrantes imigrantes
são todas as pessoas que simplesmente
não nasceram no país
se você for comparar países como estados
unidos alemanha canadá
esse curso esse percentual de migrantes
atingir os dois dígitos
esse problema não é só da europa da
síria porque era fácil a gente vê na
televisão a crise de refugiados
esse é simples e com pessoas morrendo no
mar ou ver aquelas crianças e se
identificar porque poderia ser um dos
nossos filhos
mas o que estava acontecendo aqui no
brasil estava acontecendo aqui do nosso
lado a gente estava fechando os olhos
num problema que também é nosso
foi aí que eu decidi que era hora de dar
o meu salto de fé e começar a empreender
hoje o leão trabalha para desenvolver o
protagonismo de imigrantes e refugiados
a gente trabalha com a recolocação deles
no mercado de trabalho com a capacitação
para o empreendedorismo e também com
mediação dentro das escolas e das
empresas
paralelo a gente tenta criar um ambiente
de conscientização empoderamento mas sem
colocar ele no papel de vítimas mas
sempre como pessoas com plenas condições
de passar todo o seu conhecimento sua
experiência e sua visão de mundo
você criar um ambiente de diversidade
cultural é fomentar todo um ecossistema
de criatividade e inovação não é
exatamente isso que a gente precisa num
período de crise
quando você vivendo todas essas
experiências
eu fui entendendo que o país em que eu
nasci ele pode dizer muito sobre mim mas
definitivamente não é o que me define
vestir um véu ou falar outra língua é
apenas um detalhe diante todas as
possibilidades que determinam as minhas
escolhas como preparar para olhar um
pouco para as nossas origens
nós somos toda essa mistura de culturas
de crenças e de línguas a nossa essência
essa diversidade de crenças e culturas o
que a gente vê aqui é só uma parte do
todo
lá fora há um milhão de outros mundos
possíveis só cabe a nós perceber que a
gente é pequeno diante de tudo o que a
gente pode ser gigante através das
nossas ações
obrigado